the Democratic Party is changing very
fast and if you know this better than
former Connecticut Senator Joe Lieberman
he lost a primary fight during his
party's last left word swing over a
decade ago now this week he wrote a
piece begging Democrats not to vote for
Alexandria Acacio Cortez
she's the Democratic Socialist in New
York who's almost certain to win a
congressional seat this fall electing
her Ocasio Cortes Lieberman says would
hurt the Congress hurt the Democratic
Party and hurt America Senator Joe
Lieberman of Connecticut joins us
tonight senator thank you for coming on
great to be with you Tucker thank you
so this candidate is being presented and
may indeed be the future of the
Democratic Party her ideas are the
cutting edge of progressive politics
right now why is that bad well obviously
she's got a right to her ideas but if
her ideas take hold in the Democratic
Party it's not only not the Democratic
Party that I joined a long time ago in
the inspiration of John F Kennedy
progressive on social issues
domestically kind of pro-business
pro-growth in terms of economic policy
and a strong foreign policy based on
American national interest and and
values I mean she calls herself a
Democratic Socialist to me she's more of
a socialist than a Democrat and that's
not good for the party that though it
rejected me in Connecticut in 2006 I
continue to be a member of although I'm
obviously independent and who I support
including John McCain in 2008 so you
know what really worried about me about
this after Koziol cortez beat Joe
Crowley during the campaign she called
for the abolition of ice immigration
Customs Enforcement section it made no
sense I can come back to that but after
she won three credible Democratic
candidates for president in 2020
embraced the same call and it's like the
old story about rose fear during the
French Revolution I got to get out in
front of the mob those are my followers
they're you know that what happened to
Rove spear at the end do you remember it
didn't end well
for rows so that's kind of the question
I wanted to ask you so I think you can
have a real debate on all of these
issues but the one that you just
highlighted abolishing ice deeply
unpopular with the public it's gonna be
hard to win a campaign on that issue and
I think on the merits it's a bad idea
I'm sure a lot of leaders in your party
feel that way they agree with you
they're not saying it in public where
are the adults it I agree not enough I
mean the substantive lis unless you're
against all enforcement of immigration
and customs laws you need an enforcement
agency like ice these folks are against
the Trump administration's immigration
policy they can't make a rational
argument against the ice so where are
they pick more people should be speaking
out it was kind of interesting that when
Ocasio Cortes beat Crowley somebody
asked Nancy Pelosi about it and she said
that was in one progressive district it
doesn't represent the Democratic Party
around the country which I found
heartening also very practical because
the Democratic Party will not have any
chance of retaking the house if the
image of the party is Democratic
Socialist it just doesn't work Democrats
don't like the idea of socialists in
power in America because it's not who we
are Democrats are more liberal and
immigration obviously that's fine but
you can't find a democratic office
holder who will explain clearly and I've
tried night after night what exactly our
border policy should be you can't get a
vigorous defense of the idea of borders
out of a leading Democrat right now and
some of them like Keith Ellison are
openly saying borders are themselves
racist they're inherently immoral
porter's how do you feel about that as
you watch well that that just doesn't go
with me anyway a country great thing
about America let me say first is that
from the beginning we never defined
ourselves primarily by our borders but
by our values in the Constitution
regulation of Independence but once you
say that you got to have borders you
have to have rules for who can come in
and who can't come in I happen to be
generally positive about immigration of
what it
and has done for our country and can't
still do but not but not just open the
borders and see anybody can come in
that's that's a country without rules
and we are a country of laws so Muskaan
dove policy it's never gonna make it in
America even though most Americans I
think have a generally favorable
attitude toward new Americans who are
immigrants I think that I think that's
true senator thank you very much for
joining us and I appreciate it Thank You
Tucker a good discussion